With other social media,
I'm not sure,
but I have no doubt that read it is
improving my life.
Reddit is hive,
mind meets extreme democracy.
It has the personality of a single human
being,
but it also reflects the personalities
of millions of people all around the
world.
The uniformity of sensibility which can
be seen on the front page where the most
popular links are found becomes much
more amazing.
When I see that in the last month,
reddit had $90,
million,
946,972
unique visitor as hank green might say.
I'm not going to get my mind around
that.
Speaking of Hank Green and the vlog
brothers Nerdfighteria,
their online community is a smaller but
analogous example to the reddit
universe.
Nerdfighteria has its own events like
the project for awesome and its own
eccentricities like pizza John or
sharpie face or peanut butter face.
In the same way reddit has its own
personality traits like its obsession
with memes.
Video Games,
the asked me anything feature or explain
like I'm five.
It has its own politics right now.
For example,
it's really invested in the NSA scandal
and issues concerning Internet
censorship.
There are things it hates,
like improper reddick.
One thing I discovered this week is that
reddit dislikes the creation of new
means for my friend's 30th birthday.
All his friends came together to make
him into a popular meme.
Um,
it's called the sad elias meme and you
can find the link for it in the
description and submit anything to it
that you want.
Um,
but when I tried to post our examples to
read it,
I found out that making memes of
pictures that you've taken is a ban
double offense.
A banana bowl events in its countless
subreddits,
communities are more specific and
cultish and like the dark side of
Tumblr,
Reddit has its fair share of porn and
nasty shit.
Here's a perfect example of what I love
about reading.
This is a screenshot I took of an Ama
with Lord.
It starts with Lord answering a question
about her seeming fixation with teeth in
her lyrics.
And she admits the obsession,
but says that she hates dentists.
And the first response is a Seinfeld
reference.
He's just a dentist.
And your an anti identity.
Then the second response is a comedic
use of the transitive property of
equality.
Then we have a run of dentists and teeth
related puns in which Lord rejoins the
conversation with a pun of her own.
Then someone makes a teeth and Lord
Related Pun.
Then someone finds an image of what that
pun describes and then the next person
shares the link to that artists other
work.
Remember,
the comments aren't chronological.
They're based on upvotes,
which means that the order they appear
in represents what redditors care about
the most.
In this case,
clever references,
puns,
Fan art,
and proper attribution.
My favorite thing about reddit is that
it's almost 100 percent content based
though millions of people contribute to
it.
They do so anonymously.
It's not mixed up with the pathetic
local fame obsessions of facebook and
instagram or the much larger fame
obsessions of Youtube personalities like
myself in the social media war between
platforms that represent social and
platforms that represent media.
Reddit is the purest representation of
the nobler side.
Yeah.
Yes.
So you probably want to know why I
haven't posted a video and I don't even
know how many months,
lot of reasons.
Laziness,
disgusted with the form.
Still a little bit disgusted with it.
I'm 60 vlogs straight.
I just was burnt out.
I had nothing more to say,
but mostly I just wanted to try other
things.
And one of the things I did try was
making music.
I just released an APP,
uh,
under my dj producer name,
which is strum stick called new
disguises.
You can find it on spotify,
soundcloud,
itunes,
wherever.
Go listen to it.
I spent a lot of time and effort on it
and I'm,
I'm proud of it.
And it's something that I want to
explore much,
much further.